on here in round five it's eric hanson
from canada the very famous chess
streamer against dingler and tournament
leader before the start of today and uh
where is the bar there's the bar ah it's
uh over to the inside
yep um just doing a quick scan of the
position it's level material level
pieces um it looks pretty balanced on
the face of it but if you look at the
quality of some of the pieces black's
rook has entered the second rank deep in
white's camp it's going to cause some
real nuisance now uh for the rest of the
game and black's knight on the c5 square
that is on a beautiful outpost uh yeah
it does feel like black is in charge
that being said the position has just
repeated itself once we saw black's
queen move across white's knight attack
it the queen go back the white knight go
back so a bit of a dance there i don't
think ding is going to repeat the
position again and allow the draw i
think he'll play for the win but he just
needs to come up with it from the
opposite perspective david let's take a
look there are no weaknesses in the
white's camp
there is only one square on c5 yes rook
entered the camp but we can't see any
any frets direct frets also there is a
bit of less
less space for for black there is also
potential outpost on b5 there are some
problems with opponent before so dink
has to to decide how he continues uh
objectively i i agree there there is a
slight plus for black but it's not easy
to play yeah i mean it's definitely
still a lot of life left in this
position
and uh just judging by ding's body
language as well he just kind of looked
away for a minute as if he okay i was
gonna say as if he might take the draw
and might just try and get out of this
game but okay he's coming up with a
different plan so i guess his idea of
getting is just to retreat the black
queen back one square next move and try
and use the black queen and black light
square bishop on this long diagonal
exactly he uh he offers to repeat again
with knight d4 but then bishop goes to
a8
and queen b7 this is what
david mentioned so he won't potentially
try and uh repeat the position he wants
to ideally keep it going for as long as
possible okay and uh i have an idea for
eric i mean you know eric does have an
amazing dark square bishop what happens
if he and there you go it's on the board
eric played the idea i want it which is
basically just as a plonker knight on
the h5 square and just say hey
gonna go for the attack because where's
your queen offside
yeah be three square in previous game be
six square in this game we can find some
similarities now this is a kind of bit
of a roll the dice because if it goes
wrong it's going to go really badly
wrong because some some action is
happening on the left side
and also knight on f4 helps to control
potential break in the center with d5 so
dink has to to take the concrete
decision about knight h5 there is the
threat there is the threat
both knights potentially could pounce to
that square say if black okay let's just
look for a sensible move
okay let's say i retreat one square it
feels a bit shaky somehow but now i
guess one of the ideas could be to jump
forward with your knight yeah there's a
lot to calculate here actually with the
pawn in the center and um just to
demonstrate white's ideas now you
utilize this bishop on the long diagonal
and you try to break through towards the
black king also ideas later swinging the
queen across and uh going for checkmate
so very similar ideas actually to the
last game as you guys mentioned the
black queen offside at least temporarily
okay this move has happened
and uh will we see white go on the
attack now i think it's quite likely and
uh
often
yeah perhaps the inca simply wants to
cut the long diagonal in case of knight
h5 after trading the knights and playing
e5 and trying to get queen g3 g6 the the
the barrier
and at the same time attacking the pawn
on e4 so the knight on h5 potentially
might be also offside of play
yeah so
big moment here
can white afford the time to go on the
attack but maybe it doesn't quite work
yet and you might live to regret
spending that time or do you just take
out take out a moment to play a quiet
move as eric chooses to do just
solidifying his central pawn here and
trying to say to black okay i still have
time to build up before what's going on
with the bar here you guys it's crazy it
goes from one side to another with every
single move here i think that just means
it gives a lot of play you know it
doesn't quite know i mean maybe it
thinks black has to the
strategic trumps but then at the same
time white makes a move and it's like oh
yeah i quite like that move so yeah i
think you got to go by your instincts
and maybe by the clock situation because
i mean things can go wrong in these
types of positions i mean maybe eric
will
really throw in everything towards the
black king and it might not work in
which case ding will be very successful
with his counter attack in the center
or on the other hand it might be ding
who is caught on the wrong foot and with
all his play on the center it might be
the action that on the king side on the
right side that is going to decide
everything and you mentioned the clock
times potentially being a big factor of
anchor eric is one of the fastest
players out there he's great at bullet
chess he's obviously part of the chess
bra channel but he's competed against
the likes of nakamura for years at
bullet chess and he's vastly experienced
some great results there and ding
obviously he's great as well as speeches
greater blitz but
i think the shorter they get on time the
more random it will become
and eric will for sure fancy his own
chances especially if he gets some kind
of attack going and the clock situation
is roughly level and actually if
anything now eric's going to be feeling
confident ding under one minute he's
still got two minutes left himself yeah
anything can happen in this game despite
what the evaluation bar says let's just
ignore that
okay and ding just playing a bit of a
mysterious move there moving his rook to
a defense he doesn't know quite what to
do so he's just playing a non-committal
move
and
he's preparing a faith square for the
bishop
he wants to
to save the king so he he didn't find
the exact exact threat and exact defense
against the knight h5 so uh knight h5
yes delivering some pieces to the king's
side but then
you have to guard your seven pawn and
rocate
is preparing for that
actually it's a very nice time coming
for the game a time for what we like uh
computer chess internet chess yeah uh
nerves and uh a lot of blunders would
happen
clearly even with plus 10 seconds
increment really yeah
i think you're right for sure we'll see
at least one or two blunders from each
side not sir not just from one player
wow okay a nice sacrifice by eric and
you saw him kind of react to his own
move there he's getting excited and uh
maybe this was what ding was trying to
protect against as well so white's
knight has sacrificed itself white uh
the black pawn can just take that knight
but white will recapture with a pawn and
suddenly the e file would have opened up
while its bishops are opened up towards
the black king
yes and you see the back uh backrank
mate takes d5 e takes d5 and then uh
eric captures the knight on f6 you can
show this on board quickly because this
dink would never blunder
uh in case bishop d7 bishop f6 bishop f6
then mate is coming this is very nice a
queen sacrifice breaking through on the
back rank and this is checkmate because
black's escape square this one is
actually covered by the white bishop so
yeah and it's very impressive that eric
found this idea for like 20 seconds
thinking only for 20 seconds very fast
reaction what a guy is ready to play a
bullet yeah what a move
putting your knight on praise where it
can actually be captured three times and
uh actually after this trade black is
currently a knight for just to pawn out
but look at these bishops they're going
to try and
attack the black king and okay black has
actually just given the piece back let's
go back to the players there's so much
drama here there's now an attack against
the white queen how will eric deal with
this look at the evaluation bar let's
maybe slightly trust it now i was gonna
say no
let's not but uh yeah this one anything
can happen white's queen under attack i
guess white can just move it uh just
couldn't retreat it but it is also very
tempting to sacrifice it here for the
rook
this is what i was going to say yeah
first instinct to sacrifice to pin the
kink uh now the knight delivery friendly
knight f5 pawn is hanging on the 6 97
maybe
dink has to retreat the rook on 8 at
least to trade one pair of rooks uh at
the moment
um
yeah this would be amazing this is the
solution this is the solution and i i i
believe uh
now eric is uh a little bit struggling
to decide because in bullet game in any
kind of blitz game he would clearly take
on it but 10 seconds is something yeah
yeah chess players are artists right and
they always want to win in a flashy way
it's not just about winning a game it's
winning in a flashy way and this queen
sacrifice if we see it would lead to
fireworks so let's go back to the
players let's see uh how they react now
that they are both down to around 30
seconds eric has his head in his hands
he wants to sacrifice his queen he's
just plucking up the courage yeah i
don't think he's going to do it i think
it involves too much risk and as we all
know perfectionism it is a sin
and he he retreats his queen i wasn't
thinking he would do that i thought that
he might place his queen one square out
up on the diagonal
so okay no queen sacrifice yet no
fireworks yet but still a lot of drama
about to happen we saw a rook trade
black is grabbed upon blacks are pawn up
now but still some potential attacking
ideas look at those white bishops look
where they're pointing towards the black
king so who's going to handle the time
pressure better oh i'm excited for the
time scramble that i guess is about to
start here we go okay a queen move just
centralizing re-centralizing the queen
putting some pressure on the black
knight in the center
i still feel like this position i can't
guess the moves anymore exactly so
everything depends on the style of the
players somebody in such a situation is
trying to get all in positions like
delivering the pieces and to decide the
game immediately somebody is playing
very accurate look at this he will
sacrifice the exchange he will sacrifice
the exchange from b2 deliver knight on
c3 long diagonal kind of dark squared
flame brave move though that is such a
brave move by opening up the diagonal of
the dark squares towards the black king
if you imagine white's queen picking
itself up and dropping itself actually
in the corner square next to the black
king that would be checkmate if white's
queen can line itself up on that
diagonal but as you guys said black
would have sacrificed something to stop
that idea happening yeah and now there's
an immediate threat in the board uh
queen takes night is going to be
happening wow yeah
i wish we had more time to show some of
these ideas but there's so much
happening on the board right now black
has just sacrificed the exchange a rook
for a bishop
i i think ding has lost the plot i think
there's two too many weaknesses here
okay it's still anyone's game black has
given up a rook for a bishop but now
there is a trick in the position black's
knight on an outpost if white takes that
knight twice so for example knight takes
knight the pawn will recapture it the
white queen takes then black's bishop
suddenly on the dart squares will come
and cause some trouble i i believe it
will be kind of strategical play now he
would place the bishop on c4 like
replacing bishop bishop c4 and
potentially trying to attack the black
skink
and uh yeah it's going to be
really bad news for ding on the light
squares yeah like you said
there is very good news on the dark
square so and it looks like kind of
fortress even magnus doesn't believe
they exist
so bishop gonna be on d4 and uh yeah
both bishops
yeah both bishops pointing towards the
enemy kings and um white's rook at least
for the next few moves will not be too
active black knight does control
i don't know i mean if i was playing
this position i would just be looking at
the clock being like okay let's play
quick moves quick music moves and set
some traps but uh yeah now there's a
huge threat in the position black's
queen trying to come down um
giving a nasty check how does white stop
that
okay just giving some breathing space to
the white king this is nice because at
least the king can hide on a light
square yeah i think we'll see white's
king hiding on the light square black's
king also trying to hide on the opposite
colour to the opponent's bishop
white is struggling to play without the
rook rook on c2 is outplayed but
potentially in case it will be
maneuvered d3 f3 uh kind of
responsibility you'll get there
100 what do you guys think if the queens
get traded at some point who will that
favor that is always a question in these
really complex middle games i think they
will favor black i think it will favor
black yeah because black is under some
potential long-term pressure on the
light squares that combination of the
queen and the bishop so
okay so this is probably why ding has
advanced his pawn two squares forward
you know getting ready to trade off
queens yeah he could have traded queens
immediately that's uh
slightly surprising to me that he has
pushed a pawn near his king especially
while the queens remain especially when
the clocks are so low
um i mean that move maybe it would come
to my mind but so much risk involved oh
sorry to interrupt i i i just i i i just
believe that ding is playing for a win
and without queens he clearly playing
just to to to hold the draw with the
dark squares
bishop on d4 knight on c3 so um my
belief uh by playing f5 ding guarded his
king like pawn on f7 which you've been
hanging all the time and preparing the
jump knight on e4 to put some extra
pressure to f2 pawn but uh structure is
uh like clearly fixed at the moment and
um
i don't know very very surprising uh he
he loves to enter queen sister queen is
now gonna come in i saw both of your
faces immediately after that move just
looking confused and i'm confused too
because white's queen can now deliver a
nasty check and black's king
it's gonna be struggling to survive okay
okay the queen just drops back one
square now the queen is going to be
outplayed by 94 i believe yeah very
surprising move from both sides there
black's queen just kind of placing
itself offside allowing some nasty
checks eric hansen not taking that
opportunity and now some big threats
against the viking maybe
okay white's bishop dropping back trying
to trade itself off for that strong
black knight i understand this is a very
confusing position for you guys yeah i
imagine how the players are feeling as
well they've got the clock pressure on
them as well we're confused in the
studio we've got all the time in the
world uh but the players they're having
to handle this with seconds left and
white now threatening the black knight
in two different ways with the rook with
the queen also some nasty checks against
the black king coming back
now he's going to come to the open line
sorry stole it yeah yeah yeah just uh
coming to it so that that was my idea as
well
well imagine what uh a winner would mean
for eric hanson one of the lower ranked
players in the tournament if he wins
against england that would be a huge
result for him yep it would be
phenomenal and also it would shake up
the rankings completely no longer feel
completely safe about qualification
despite a great day yesterday and
actually ding there he's just brought
his knight back where it came from so
eric if he wants to play safe i was
going to say can eliminate that night
and uh yep he had options there maybe he
could have activated his rook as well um
there was a lot to work out but he's
eliminated black's knight will we see a
queen trade will black's queen capture
or will black just take back with the
pawn if black takes that bishop back
with the pawn white's rook will swing
across and
yeah
rookie two is mate
in case of queen of war he dingle has to
to calculate yeah uh
rookie two and he's losing the pawn yeah
so exactly if that okay look at ding's
face he did not look happy there if that
black pawn in the middle falls it's
going to be game over almost the white
rook will eventually find itself in a
more active square and uh yeah brooks
are just better than bishops in n games
and it's not just the rook it's also the
fact that the white king is going to be
much more active than its counterpart as
well yeah both kings were much towards
the center now i guess and arcade ding
he knows that he couldn't let the white
king continue its journey that would
have just been game over so he's giving
up another pawn he's at least going to
create one strong pawn of his own but
this can be stopped by white's rook yep
okay there you go it's stopped on the
first row yeah and white has one pawn
extra and the rook versus bishop
advantage once white's king activates
it's gonna be game over ding
not looking happy eric this is a huge
result for him super impressive and
imagine these two they're sitting
just complete opposite opposite sides of
the world it's early morning for eric
hanson it's super late night for dingle
run
maybe that's the reason here on the
camera it looks the other way around
yeah
um yeah white has a few ways to win this
position you can for example just bring
the rook across in front of the black
pawn blockade it and then just march
your king back and uh eliminate that
black pawn with your rook at some point
but
maybe there are other ways as well yeah
ding is hoping to get the pawn on g3 but
this is just a little hope to
to postpone their resign
yep some final tricks left maybe for
ding but uh eric should be able to guide
this one to victory now this is just as
a matter of technique as they say right
yeah there's always some tricks in the
position but if your technique is good
you should be able to win when you have
a material advantage like this one
and the king does come back and black
does go after white's kingside pawns
yep black's strong pawn about to fall
but uh yeah more importantly the rest of
his pawns are falling as well this is a
very clever move actually by eric
eliminating some potentially dangerous
pawns
and yeah king and bishop are not able to
control both pawns i believe the c pawn
will roll pretty fast yeah too many
pawns if white only had one point left
maybe some decent chances to hold a good
uh hold the game but
um yeah it's going to take an age for
black's remaining pawn that h pawn too
yeah but i have the feeling that
something would happen in this game you
know two pawns like bishop f6 h4 like
controlling maybe the c pawn uh
their side pawn is running and bishop is
pretty strong and you have only half
minute left
of course objectively like let's never
talk like this in the rapid chess
i mean we've seen some twists and turns
already right so yeah there might be one
or two left in store white now attacking
the black bishop where is that bishop
going to go it does want to stay on the
diagonal it sits on to stop white's c
pawn advancing up the board but it's not
easy to maintain it on that diagonal
the problem after bishop f6 that
the opponent game is lost
this is like white is playing uh rook of
eight pin and sephon runs faster and
promoting with a check in some lines
yeah so if the black bishop moves the
white pawn the white seaport will decide
the game yeah it's
looking difficult although the
evaluation part isn't completely it has
definitely gone down yeah
i guess there might be a square for
black bishop where to put it do you
bring it the whole way down to the a3
square to just guard blacks from black's
pawn
that b2 pawn maybe simple bishop c5 to
to block to block the c pawn and
attacking e pawn okay nh4 yeah
everything is possible so exactly the
bishop chooses a square where it does
potentially hold up the advance of
either of white's two remaining horns
so very interesting move that from ding
he's going to hope that even if his pawn
falls on this side of the board that his
other pawn the h pawn is going to run
and at least uh cause
cause white to give up a rook or maybe
lose a few tempe in the process a few
moves instead eric i think this is just
his bullet technique coming in handy uh
he's just trying to gain a bit of time
by attacking black's bishop
and uh black's bishop though maybe it's
improved i'm not sure it's winning
anymore bishop 25 is so strong
controlling both sides and controlling
the c pawn i think this last yeah been
very inaccurate i mean that's the type
of position we would just grab the black
pawn off the board and then think later
uh even in classical chess probably but
maybe eric just trying to be a bit too
clever there i mean but now it's a race
it's a race you know now the pawn can
advance
and i'm working very far down the board
already
but ding's idea is pretty simple right
just run with it with harry and see how
far it goes ding has nothing else to do
apart from push's pawns and that's quite
a good thing in rapid chess when you
only have one idea you only have one
move or one plan
eric now shaking his head he knows it's
not easy anymore and the computer agrees
the wind maybe has gone
and he's got to be careful not to
actually lose control on the board and
of his emotions and lose this game
because the black pawns are both still
alive it's very important that there is
no h8 square the bishop is too strong so
the h pawn might simply roll down and
you can blunder the rook i i can't
remember how many rooks on h8 in such
situations i blundered in my life that
would be very similar to my blunder
against play magnus age 10 yesterday
just put the rook on a square it could
be captured
so that's why eric dropped his rook back
one square he's gonna
swing it across
and look at those two black pawns on his
head now now he's destroyer yeah
oh no
just no way to win this game black's
king can actually just go and pick up
some of the white pawns now white's king
is tied down to one pawn white's rook is
tied down to the other and look how
strong black's bishop is black's bishop
guarding both the remaining pawns and
black's king i guess is just going to
step back now
both moves i think are fine yeah shaking
is it a good idea now maybe for the rook
just to capture the pawn and just go
let's call it a draw yeah i don't think
white's going to lose this one anymore
but as you say your ankle white can give
up the rook for both black pawns and the
bishop alone is not going to give
checkmate
there we go it's going to be a draw any
moment eric went down to two seconds
with his last move
but uh yeah that white horn once it
falls the game will be a draw
a very important draw for dink because i
think he's challenging himself and kind
of
current world situation without
opportunity for traveling so